we won the election twice
inspired by former president donald
trump's falsehoods about widespread
fraud in the 2020 election
republican-controlled state legislatures
in 19 states have passed 34 new laws
restricting access to voting there is an
assault underway on
the very structure of our elections in
our democracy that is carrying forward
the assault that we saw on january 6th
of 2021 on the united states capital
president joe biden called out trump in
his january sixth speech the former
president
and his supporters have decided the only
way for them to win
is to suppress your vote
and subvert our elections
for example in the swing state of
georgia new laws make it harder to
request mail ballots bar election
officials from sending applications for
those ballots restrict the number of
drop boxes and polling places in heavily
democratic urban areas and make it a
crime to offer food or water to people
waiting in long lines for a chance to
vote states including georgia have gone
further passing laws that would
undermine nonpartisan election agencies
and officials and even allow partisan
officials to reject election results
entirely
senate democratic party leader charles
schumer says he will introduce two bills
this month that would allow the justice
department to undo state restrictive
voting laws republicans have blocked
those efforts before using the
parliamentary maneuver called the
filibuster which requires a super
majority of votes in the senate
it's not a voting rights bill it's a
sprawling sweeping
takeover
of our democracy
schumer says if the republicans block it
again he will try to eliminate the
filibuster for voting rights legislation
if this continues the only option left
for democrats
is to explore and propose reasonable
fixes to restore the senate
so we can get these critical pieces of
legislation passed into law
trump's big lie about the 2020 election
amplified by right-wing media has had an
impact
in january of 2021 a poll showed that 59
of americans said they trusted that
elections represented the will of the
american people by september of last
year the majority had flipped to where
now 52 say they do not
that is a threat to the very fabric of
our democracy another recent poll shows
34 percent of americans believe acts of
violence against the government are
sometimes justified
2022 will be a crucial year with
congressional elections in november
trump will hold his first rally of the
year in arizona this week
and former first lady michelle obama
announced her voting rights organization
will lead a drive to register one
million new voters this year
rob reynolds al jazeera